now as the Democrats rushed to discredit
our democracy GOP leaders are fighting
back today House Minority Leader Kevin
McCarthy sent House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
a letter demanding she end impeachment
inquiries until quote equitable rules
and procedures are put in place in our
next guest also filed an amicus brief in
federal court today contesting the
legality of the entire inquiry
congressman Doug Collins arguing the
house must vote before the process
begins which did not happen here Ken
Starr raised that issue last night
joining me now congressman Doug Collins
ranking member of the House Judiciary
Committee congressman how can the
Democrats run a credible investigation
without Republicans really involved well
they can't Laura this is the part and
I'm sure at the point I'm just I've had
it I've been nine months of this I've
been Judiciary Committee watching Jerry
Nadler and his happy battle majority run
roughshod over rules they don't care
about the rules they want one thing at
the end of the day and that is to
impeach this president they've wanted to
do this in November of 2016 and that's
why when we've been talking about
fairness and at the end of the day
people understand fairness they may
disagree with this president may not
even like this president but they
understand when you have a speaker of
the house who refuses to bring the
inquiry to the floor why does that
matter
because if she made her Democrats vote
for an inquiry and they started a true
inquiry then actually we in the minority
have rice myself would have subpoena
power in the Judiciary Committee just
like chairman Adler would the president
could actually weigh in with his team to
say actually be accused
isn't that a unique concept war in
America we actually believe that people
have due process rights but this speaker
is running roughshod over the house and
it's got to stop this is a travesty and
it's affecting the institution of the
house it's affecting how people laid out
on the angle congressman how people view
our our Democratic Republic how people
view the press how people you know view
the entire concept of fairness the
president is being hamstrung and his
ability to conduct foreign policy I'm
sorry but the China North Korea the way
they look at all this this is they don't
one wit about how this affects our
economy or anything else it's about
tearing down this president ripping him
out of office by any means necessary and
I got to ask you Nancy Pelosi gave an
interview on ABC where I think she
revealed perhaps unwittingly what's
really going on watch the reelection of
Donald Trump would do irreparable damage
to United States this that we have some
serious repair and healing to do in our
country for what he's done so far I
don't I'm not sure that two terms it
might be irreparable to okay so that's
it right they mean we can't risk the
people voting for peace and prosperity
cannot risk it you know it is amazing to
me that speaker Pelosi has such little
faith in the American people if she was
right if she had an agenda if she
believed that the democratic party
candidates for president were actually
on the right track actually sharing the
right message then why is she so
skeptical of the American people
actually voting for what they believe is
through out ideas the problem is she
knows that Donald Trump is of connecting
with American people he did it in 2016
we're gonna see it again next year and
what they're seeing from her is simply I
wanting to overturn an election because
the next election they're scared of what
is causing irreparable damage is her
second term as Speaker this is her
second time around the speaker what do
we get the first time we got Obamacare
we got all kinds of things that we're
now having to still dig out of
now shut already yeah oh yeah
shovel-ready heard know what
shovel-ready is what she's spreading to
the american people about what they're
doing with this impeachment inquiry
that's shovel-ready because it's not
anywhere close she's lying to the
american people that's why our amicus
brief was filed if they wanted this
information they know they have to
they're telling the people one thing and
not congressman Fox News has confirmed
just confirmed that the president will
send Pelosi a letter tomorrow that the
White House is going to ignore Democrat
demands until the house formally
approves impeachment proceedings he's
daring her to hold an impeachment vote
good move well I think what you're gonna
have to have is is there you know we
scared right now about 30 or 40
Democrats and seats the president drop
one they're gonna have to gag the golden
record now and say look miss Pelosi the
Speaker Pelosi if you want to take us
down this path then you're recognizing
it
you're putting in jeopardy the House
Majority that you won last year on a
platform if you were gonna do something
for the American people you're gonna do
trade you're gonna do infrastructure
you're gonna do prescription drug prices
you've done none of that except attack
this president and also at the same time
by the way take the rules of the house
and throw them in the trash can this is
the problem that we're having right now
if you want to do it properly if you
want to do it by the book then do that
but speaker Pelosi chairman Naylor
chairmanship who hasn't found it I mean
I can't he can't spell truth much less
tell it and when we understand this this
is the problem we're seeing right now
they're destroying the institution in
the house and everyone Republicans
Democrats and independents ought to be
agreed now that all those swing district
Democrats got to tell you you said you
were gonna be fair and you're gonna work
with Republicans you've shown your true
colors here congressman thank you very
much it's great to have you on tonight